Jocko,
Leif and Echo
your opinion has been solicited on
this leadership question right here.
So we'll see how that works out.
A good leader ensures his team understands
what their goals are and why they are
performing tasks.
But how do you balance doing this with
not being the leader that talks so much
that the team stops listening?
We did.
We just cover this for a long period
of time. Pretty much it didn't we,
I guess we can leave it at this echo.
Do you agree with what we said earlier
or do you have a different opinion about
talking too much and mind you,
you've said a lot today, so don't be,
don't get crazy over here
or we'll stop listening.
The guy who talks too much, no, less
is more a hundred percent I agree.
There you go. I like it. I will say it.
Musters a win echos, echos
words to the audience. Um,
he always gives an epic speech,
have,
have solicited probably the greatest
applause of everyone out there. Yeah, man.
See I guess to dig in this little
bit of how to balance that with,
with being a leader that talks too much,
I think you've got to pay attention to
what the reactions are you getting from
people,
right?
You've got to pay attention to the
reactions you're getting from people.
If the people are not totally,
uh,
actively listening to you, right? If
they're not actively listening to you,
if they're taking notes,
if they're looking at their
phone or what not taking notes,
but if they're looking at their
phone or whatever, then you're,
you're talking too much.
Keep it short,
keep it concise and people will
listen to you more also that, um,
when you say you got to pay attention
to yourself, that's like a deep one.
It's like you just said it
really simply like, Oh hey,
just pay attention to yourself. I
mean, you didn't say it like that,
but that's what it felt like.
That's the hardest part right there.
Because a lot of times like,
hey,
me and life are talking and lay starts
looking at his phone. I'm not thinking,
Hey, I'm talking too much. I'm saying what
I'm saying, it's not interesting enough.
So I need,
so I need to say some more cool stuff or
I need to be more this or more of that
because I'm losing them kind of thing.
Like if I'm losing you,
the intuitive thought is not to
completely disconnect and stop talking and
that's not the intuitive thought. Seems
like when you're in a situation, Joe,
you got to pay attention to
that kind of stuff on yourself.
Jocko does this all the time.
Why do I do like the buses phone out and
start answering emails, whatever action.
You know what I got? Okay, cool.
I guess their conversations,
I do that to Dean and dean lister.
So Dean,
Dean deans, really important stuff we're
talking about here. He's like, yeah,
no what Dean does always see if it
makes him mad, right? He's got the,
he's got the pet peeve.
So Dean will be telling us something.
And so you're doing it on purpose
to get under her skin. Uh, no.
Sometimes he's saying some rambling
stuff. Right? And I've got stuff going on,
Dean, come on. I know you're
listening to this bro.
But sometimes he'll be saying something
to me and all of a sudden I'll like,
I'll like look around and,
and now I realize I'll just be watching
people do Jujitsu cause we're normally
on the mat.
Well this happens.
So he's telling me something like looking
me in the eyes and he's like, you know,
when the ancient blah blah blah blah,
he'll be telling me about
the Peloponnesian war or
something or whatever. And,
and as I'm listening to them,
I'll kind of look and I'll like start
looking at someone that's training or
looking at something and he'll,
he'll like attack me.
He went through a period where he would
just attack me and like take me down and
just start, you know, going psycho
on me. So that got me tuned up.
They've got me tuned up where I try
and give dean some more attention.
I like that. I think that's
a, I think that's a good,
do you feel like when he starts
doing that side of the bright,
I see what you're doing.
Well, the thing is though,
is that I think you're in the same boat
late for, I know you kind of know, know,
like in everyday life with
other people you might think,
I mean intuitively anyway, like,
Oh, I'm losing them or whatever.
But you can tell with him if he starts
doing that stuff and you're like, okay,
and he's, or yeah, move on or something.
But it's only because, you know,
like, listen, if you can give me
35 more seconds, we'll be done.
You can move on and do
whatever you need to.
I will say that's a bad characteristic
that I have where I can do that.
Sometimes I'm done listening to you,
so wrap it up all the time in the system.